like a lot of women want a certain type
of lifestyle that they can't afford so
they want like the like the makeup the
new clothes the lip filler Botox all
that it all adds up right and um this
woman basically said that when she does
budgeting with wife she goes down to
like three basic necessities which is
food shelter and clothing and like she
teaches them how to do hand-me-downs
with the kids and like how to work
within a budget guess how much money she
spent on a year with 10 kids
10 kids guess how much you spend on the
kids in a year guess 100K over oh a mess
yeah I guess it's gonna be shocking 50
50.
10. 10.
it was in dollars so it was eight
thousand